How would you rather go extinct? Starvation,
spears or syphilis? The Rapa Nui had all three!
Hey guys, Amy with you on DNews today. It’s
been long thought that the original people
of Easter Island killed themselves off through
war. But new information is suggesting otherwise.
Easter Island, the 64 square mile remote Chilean
territory that lies over 2,300 miles off the
South American coast, is known to most of
us as that island with the giant heads. Called
moai, these statues of human figures with
oversize heads were made by the Rapa Nui,
the island’s native Polynesian inhabitants
at some point between the 10th and 16th centuries.
But not long after erecting the impressive
statues, the Rapa Nui disappeared, and for
years archaeologists have suspects they were
killed by an environmental catastrophe they
brought upon themselves.
The commonly held theory is that humans, somewhat
miraculously, reached the small island more
than a millennium ago and quickly colonized
it. But, with these new residents also came
rats, which they either brought as a food
source or as stowaways. In any case these
rats thrived on the isolated volcanic island,
finding an ample food supply in the lush palm
trees, and with no risk of starvation, the
population quickly swelled to a few million.
The rats ate the vegetation faster than it
could regrow, eventually taking away their
own food supply. Less rat food meant less
rats and less rats meant less food for the
humans.
Tack on the fact that the local people were
also cutting down vegetation for farmland
and building materials, and you have an island
that is no longer environmentally sustainable.
Again, meaning less food for humans.
Those that didn’t die from starvation went
to war over the dwindling food supply, killing
each other with the many arrowheads archaeologists
found scattered around the island. By the
time European explorers reached the island
in 1722, there were few natives left. Those
that remained were quickly killed by western
diseases like syphilis and smallpox the Europeans
brought with them.
This theory on Easter Island’s history is
so prevalent that historians use it as a cautionary
tale of the perils that comes from abusing
the scant natural resources available in a
small environment. But new research is challenging
this long-held theory. Archaeologists’ continued
fieldwork on the remote island now suggests
that disease and slavery brought by Europeans
played a much larger role in killing the Rapa
Nui than their own environmental demise.
The findings, published in the journal Antiquity,
point to one specific thing. Do you remember
when I talked about those arrowheads the Rapa
Nui used to kill each other with? Well, it
turns out, they aren’t arrowheads at all.
They’re not even weapons.
Those carved, sharp pointed pieces of obsidian,
a rock made of volcanic glass, are called
mata’a, and after analyzing 423 of them,
a team of scientists has has now determined
that the objects aren’t suited for killing
humans, they’re more suited to be a general
purpose tool. They could have been used for
anything from cultivating the land to ritual
scarification to tattooing.
As lead author on the recent study Carl Lipo
of Binghamton University, New York, explained
to the BBC, a weapon would be long and thin,
like a sword, basically something primed for
piercing an organ without having to get too
close to an enemy. The points on Easter Island
are just too short and flat. They are more
reminiscent of a spade than a spear making
them tools for survival, like digging and
farming.
So if the Rapa Nui didn’t kill themselves,
that shifts the blame firmly onto the Europeans
explorers. While rats eating the palm trees
and the Rapa Nui felling them the trees to
clear land and make fires would have changed
the environment, it seems they remained a
sustainable community for centuries. It wasn’t
until the Europeans brought disease and enslaved
the native Islanders that they were put on
the road to near extinction.
So the Rapa Nui might be gone, but at least
we can rebuild their history through rich
archaeological analysis. But analysing pointed
stones isn’t the only way scientists are
recovering lost civilizations. Julian’s
got the skinny on how scientists are using
LiDAR to unveil lost cities.
And if you want to keep updated on all things
science, be sure to check out TestTube’s
newsletter! Get a weekly round-up of our most
popular videos across all our shows at TestTube.com/fwd
What mysteries of ancient civilizations would
you guys like to know more about? Let us know
in the comments below and don’t forget to
subscribe for more DNews every day of the
week.